[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de page
consacrée à l'économie face au virus et
les entreprises aussi face à la crise
sanitaire connaissait les chiffres il ya
une baisse de 9,1 pour cent du pib en
2020 on attend un rebond de 6% pour
l'année prochaine mais quelles sont les
réalités derrière ces chiffres en
matière d'activité d'emploi notamment
sur le territoire des yvelines pour en
parler
aymeric de la boissière bonjour mange
vous êtes président du comité des
banques yvelines nicolas mas villebon
joujou nous allons jouer grand mère de
la verrière conseiller départemental des
yvelines et vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'emploi
et puis nicolas landry bonjour vous êtes
très influent des listes atv 78 on va
recevoir dans un instant un chef
d'entreprise qui va qui va nous
rejoindre qui jean-luc hareng qui est
président de da2 sécurité sune au
travail de de sécurité deux incendies
qui situe à bûches les dans les yvelines
et puis on aura aussi des noms à des
missions nattawut de jean-noël barrot
qui est économiste qui surtout le député
de la 2e circonscription des yvelines et
vice présidente de la commission des
finances
nicolas jules tête commencez par vous
pour vous pour vos façades tableau de la
situation
quels sont les chiffres notamment en
matière de chômage partiel g20 de début
novembre à je crois une situation de
début novembre des chiffres communiqués
par le service de l'état donc début
novembre 28 mille demandes ont été
effectuées le pardon que vingt-huit
mille demandes 28 mille entreprises du
coup de chômage partiel ont été
effectués pour 327 1000 salariés dans le
département
au 17 octobre c'était 57 % des
établissements s'est représenté 57
constante des établissements du
département soit 65% des effectifs qui
travaillent dans le département des
yvelines nicolas naville mais justement
est-ce qu'on peut dresser un état des
lieux de l'emploi dans les yvelines et
et est ce qu'on peut craindre aussi que
l'heure de vérité ne sonne dans les
premiers mois de 2000 21 bien évidemment
alors dans les yvelines on n'a pas
toutes les données mais en tout cas sur
saint quentin en yvelines
on a à peu près 13 mille demandeurs
d'emploi toutes catégories confondues
si une hausse de 25% par rapport à
l'année dernière
et quand on interroge les services de
pôle emploi
il nous parle du drôle de guerre c'est à
dire une augmentation pour l'instant pas
pas si importante que ça de manière
absolue mais beaucoup de changements
dans les catégories de demandeurs
d'emploi la veille que voilà des gens au
chômage parce qu'elles tuent deviennent
de chômage avec voilà une demande
d'emploi beaucoup plus forte et donc
avec une à risque et une crainte
effectivement d'une intensification du
chômage avec notamment les plans sociaux
on a eu un certain nombre de mauvaises
nouvelles de plans sociaux notamment
chez airbus
avec quelques mauvaises nouvelles à
venir chez renault et donc des secteurs
qui sont touchés donc effectivement il
ya un riff surtout pour demain oui c'est
vrai qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont très
présents sur ce sur ces territoires dont
les yvelines et notamment une terrine
point de 50 ans qui sont l'aéronautique
et l'automobile et qui sont en effet
d'aider des secteurs qui au prix de
plein fouet la crise sanitaire est
effectivement alors on parle aussi quand
on interroge un petit peu les
spécialistes d'une crise en cas la
lettre car c'est à dire que le
confinement a mis à l'arrêt l'ensemble
de l'activité économique et suite aux
premiers confinement certaine
certains secteurs redémarre c'est le le
la lettre k qui va vers le haut c'est lé
secteur du numérique et secteur de la
santé du service à la personne du btp
qui commence à retrouver un regain
d'activité mais il ya malheureusement
des secteurs qui continuent leur leur
leur chute
c'est le cas du tourisme c'est le cas de
l'événementiel c'est le cas la
restauration restauration collective
également c'est le cas de de tout le
secteur de l'immobilier dans les
services dans les entreprises qui est
vraiment durement impactées et donc bien
évidemment c'est peut-être sur ces
secteurs là que que les aides
demain pourront se concentrer pour les
aider particulièrement aymeric des la
boissière justement quel est au contact
évidemment des des chefs d'entreprise
quel est le quel est le lot font
l'analyse que vous vous faites et que
les chefs d'entreprise faute cette
situation à ce qu' ils espèrent un
rebond d'eads en 2021 ou parce que là
ils sont plus pessimistes sur l'avenir
immédiat
en fait comme mobiliser nigra naville on
est on est sur des réactions très
différentes en fonction des secteurs
d'activité
tout ce qui est tourisme et et
communication événementielle est très
très très inquiet dans d'autres domaines
on a une grosse et spectatrices sur les
perspectives de de redémarrage
beaucoup espèrent mais à ce jour on a
effectivement comme le disait nicollin
des villes des gens qui sont sur des
tendances plutôt favorable avec des
rachats de sociétés avec des opérations
de fusions acquisitions qui seront très
développé en ce moment des opportunités
on a beaucoup de l'opération 2
de fusions acquisitions sur des
perspectives d'accroissement de prise de
parts de marché dans le quotidien
traduit au niveau entreprise par des
rachats des sollicitations pour des
crédits notamment en cette période de
fin d'année est là en ce moment on a pas
mal d'investissements les gens en
fonction de l'art était du bidon vont
nous solliciter pour renouveler du
matériel voilà donc c'est plutôt des
demandes
et puis une grosse activité pge donnera
un peu plus tard je mens
et puisque les banques elles mêmes
dans quelle situation sont elles alors
aujourd'hui nous on est économiquement
voilà la question derrière c'est de
savoir comment on va appréhender
l'avenir
aujourd'hui on est sûr on est un peu
comme tout le monde on a mis en place le
télétravail
on a mis en place des opérations de
rationalisation et de réorganisation
alors le secteur bancaire lui il évolue
ni façon très très dynamique
on est obligé de s'adapter on a eu comme
besoin de s'adapter bleus là les banques
en ligne qui sont arrivés qui l'ont
obligé à travailler sur du sur delà de
la comment s'appelle plus de la
digitalisation énorme
le fait qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a
sa langue dans sa poche via son
smartphone il ya la signature
électronique la désintermédiation
aujourd'hui il ya plus que 63 % des
crédits des entreprises qui sont
accordés elle par les banques
le reste est fait par appel direct au
marché donc on est obligé de couper de
travailler sur d'autres façons de faire
du crédit
il ya toutes ces opérations de
rationalisation où elle entendue ce
matin la générale et crédit du nord qui
fusionnent 6dans agences qui sont à
terme fermé tout le monde réfléchit à
cela il ya les opérations sur les
recherches de deux gains et de coups et
qui a trait entraîne notamment la
rationalisation du parc de distributeurs
de billets voilà il ya tout un tas
d'opérations et comme les entreprises
classiques et on essaye de s'adapter de
suivre les entrées en relation à
distance
tu fais des visites y est préparé depuis
aussi avant la crise enfin cette
utilisation la modernisation des banques
elle date de quelques années quand même
alors je vous le dis et le suit et de
9,1 pour cent en 2020 selon le président
bio mais elles sont assez fiables et
justement j'ai demandé à jean-noël
barrot dit le député de la 2e
circonscription des yvelines
quel impact concrètement allait avoir
cette baisse ça se traduit par des
mesures de soutien qui sont venus
absorber une grande partie de ce choc de
ceux de cette baisse de la richesse que
produit notre pays donc c'est ce sont
nos finances publiques qui absorbe une
partie du choc mais ce qui est devant
nous et évidemment inquiétant et il faut
y être extrêmement attentif
nous avons des commerçants des
professionnels de l'hôtellerie cafés
restauration des professionnels tourisme
des professionnels de la culture qui ont
fait pour certains une année presque
blanche et qui vont donc aborder 2021
avec eux je dirais avec des capacités
d'investissement des capacités de
recrutement qui sont très affaiblis et
puis nous avons aussi les notamment dans
les yvelines
des secteurs qui je pense à
l'aéronautique en particulier qui non
seulement ont subi jeudi rennes les
confinements comme les autres secteurs
de l'économie
mais qui en plus ont des perspectives à
deux trois quatre ans qu'ils sont
déprimés et donc ces groupes
ces groupes de l'aéronautique notamment
vont être vraisemblablement amenée ils
ont déjà commencé à prendre des
décisions difficiles en matière d'emploi
pour faciliter les transitions
inévitable vers des nouveaux marchés qui
sont un peu plus porteurs de croissance
donc en résumé c'est un choc qui a été
largement absorbés par les dispositifs
massif de soutien qui ont été mises en
oeuvre
mais c'est aussi des points de vigilance
important sur ce qui est devant nous
hier la fragilité dans lesquels dans
laquelle cette crise aura laissé un
certain nombre d'entreprises et
notamment dans les yvelines
il ya les entreprises aéronautiques et
aussi des entreprises automobiles qui
sont particulièrement touchés et qu'ils
sont nombreuses dans les yvelines
certains économistes disent au fond est
ce qu'il faut finalement l'idée des
entreprises qui risque d'être condamné
la terne ce qu'il faudrait pas mieux
mettre l'accent là aussi rosso justement
la formation formation continue la
formation professionnelle c'est c'est
une très bonne question et c'est un
point absolument fondamental il va venir
un moment où nous allons devoir
progressivement sortir des dispositifs
de de soutien qui ont été conçus pour
pour je dirais répondre très largement
et de la manière la moins discriminante
possible aux besoins des entreprises
mais on va devoir un moment donné en
sortir et il faut qu'à ce moment-là nous
puissions convertir ces dispositifs de
soutien en des dispositifs
d'accompagnement de ces transitions vous
parler de la formation professionnelle
il ya potentiellement d'autres d'autres
vecteurs de de transition de conversion
il ya des entreprises qui vont devoir
réorienter leurs activités pour rester
profitable pour rester rentables et et
donc il sera très important qu'en
complément des des mesures du plan de
relance un qui va c'est qu'ils vont
s'étaler pendant les deux prochaines
années qu'on puisse être très attentif à
tous ces secteurs toutes ces entreprises
et par conséquence tous ces territoires
qui vont devoir se réinventer pour
pouvoir rebondir rapidement
alors c'était d'un exode de l'interview
de jean noël barrot et chaque oeil
jean-luc hareng bonjour bonjour vous
êtes chef d'entreprise vaut d'être
d'origine a trouvé sa part d ad sécurité
sécurité incendie c'est un bus les et
puis vous avez une autre activité de
commerçant de qui s'appelle à pas de
loup c'est un magasin de chaussures pour
enfants donc ça serait intéressant
d'avoir vos deux la pression et puis
l'accueil aussi xavier gourlin bonjour
micro ah oui bonjour bonjour là bonjour
à la vous êtes directeur d'orange et
vous avez aussi une activité de traiteur
césar un oui alors je j'ai été un moment
donné directeur d'orange de joie était
pour moi sacré en effet à 100% dans la
deuxième activité qui est celle de
traiteur événementiel activités que nous
avons repris mon épouse ya un peu plus
de six ans de cela
alors justement on va essayer d'avoir
vos témoignages de gens lui car on va
commencer par votre activité de chef
d'entreprise des ad sécurité quand on va
sur le site d'ailleurs de votre trou
ville on voit que vous embauchez il ya
des offres d'embauché donc on se dit ça
va plutôt bien
à écouter tout d'abord merci je tenais à
vous remercier de m'avoir invité
c'est toujours un plaisir de pouvoir
évoquer un peu notre passion qui quel
chef d'entreprise
effectivement j'ai deux sociétés une qui
est de lier aux bâtiments et l'autre qui
est plutôt liée au commerce dans le dans
le premier confinement on a tous été
obligé de fermer parce qu'on n'avait pas
les les mesures
adéquates pour protéger nos
collaborateurs et nos et nos clients et
puis dans le deuxième confinement on est
le d r dc comics en dit est complètement
différent puisqu'on était liée au
bâtiment et donc du coup pas atteint
comment atteint par la mesure du
gouvernement l'a effectivement je
recrute pas ce que je souhaite que de
garder cette dynamique
bon c'est pas donné à tout le monde
aussi j'ai un peu de cash flow et donc
du coup je souhaite continuer à
dynamiser un peu l'entreprise parce que
derrière ça impacte aussi le moral des
collaborateurs ce que le moral de
collaborateurs quand vous êtes au
chômage partiel une première fois que
vous revenez que vous avez vous voyez
qui vous avez du mal à relancer la
machine
ça ça nous ça nous met dans une position
qui est complètement différente donc du
coup je souhaite garder sinon sa
dynamique et puis nous on est liée aussi
à des contrats de maintenance qui qui
sont engagés dans l'année reconductible
et donc du coup toute la partie
maintenance des extincteurs dbrs des
colonnes sèches des portes coups de feu
etc tous les moyens de secours nous
permettent de garder cette cette
fluidité et donc du coup attendre le
relance la relance au niveau du bâtiment
mais mais concrètement au niveau du
chiffre d'affaires il ya quand même une
perte alors côté des années j'ai réussi
à garder ce gir et cet équilibre au
niveau du bilan
vous utilisez beaucoup de télé de
travail
or et c'est compliqué quand même dans
votre secteur très très compliqué dans
l'allée mal à faire de la vérification
un peu à distance
donc nous on n'est pas du tout lié on
peut pas se permettre de faire du
télétravail
par contre côté côté magasin
complètement différent puisque nous on a
subi les deux confinement et donc du
coup par obligation de mettre de mettre
nos collaboratrices au chômage partiel
ou en chômage partiel
là pour le coup ça ça marche plutôt bien
et ça marche bien pour les
collaboratrices pour les chefs
d'entreprise je trouve qu'il ya quand
même une sacrée car puisqu'aujourd'hui
on n'est pas prêt à 100%
on est pris qu'à 84 % et il faut savoir
que deux dans l'ancienneté n'est pas
pris en compte les jours fériés sont pas
pris en compte les comment les congés
payés et donc du coup par obligation
c'est un commun à l'employeur de prendre
en charge tout restant pour atteindre
100%
oui mais ça touche sur le cash flow
supplémentaire un coût supplémentaire
donc vous avez une activité de traiteur
on sait que les restaurants sont
extrêmement touchés c'est même peut-être
les premières victimes de cette crise
sanitaire
est ce que c'est la même chose pour les
activités de traiteur vocaux contraire
ça développe cette activité la crise
sanitaire
non malheureusement alors en
l'occurrence pour ce qu'est notre
société nous avons un secteur d'activité
qui est très orienté sur le sur les
entreprises ans était de vraiment
traiteur événementiel à destination des
entreprises ont les deux confinement ont
été assez dramatiques pour nous en
termes de frais de d'impact ailleurs en
illustration notre chiffre d'affaires
est à peine à 30 % de ce qui a été celui
de la dernière à la même époque
donc évidemment c'est assez dramatique
et c'est vrai que pour toute la
profession de l'événementiel comme pour
les restaurateurs au delà du fait que le
même subissent des fermetures
administratives
évidemment le phénomène de je dirais de
confinement le phénomène je dirais de
distanciation gérer toute la partie
sanitaire purin qui font que les
sociétés ne font plus d'animations ce
qui est bien logique malheureusement
dans cette situation là
nous a totalement privé notre activité
principale je dirais sur ans sur cet
exercice géré et demi avec du coup et tu
m'as roulent les bloquer tout à l'heure
dans son interview est évidemment un
soutien extrêmement important je dirais
la part du gouvernement et des
institutions publiques globales y
compris la région et le département pour
aider pour nous aider ça soit au travers
j'irai des prêts évidemment le pg le
prêt anti d'état que ça soit au niveau
de la prise en charge du chômage partiel
contrairement je dirai ce que vous
évoquiez la précédemment on a la chance
de l'activité à la chance si je puis me
permettre ce terme d'être une activité
découverte à 100% sur le chômage partiel
dans ce qui évidemment nous avons pu
sauver la mise puisque quasiment 5% des
personnels deiter chômage partiel tout
au long de cette période de mars
gérer un quasiment maintenant et donc on
est sur une activité qui malheureusement
on va suivre après la sirène à la
séquence je dirais les vaccinale
malheureusement aucune activité qui va
probablement perdurer un très amoindri
au moins jusqu'à la fin du premier
semestre
le temps en effet que les aura plus de
retour d'une forme de je dirais de
confiance dans la capacité d'une part à
faire revenir voir s'équiper au delà de
ce que sera la permanence d'un
télétravail et puis la d re créer des
animations des événements qui sont dans
le sait pour autant sacrifiable quand on
est dans des problématiques après
économique donc ça en verra l'impact de
la crise sanitaire donnera aussi sur
l'impact économique qui va par la suite
mais voilà on est assez pessimiste en
tout cas sur la retour à l'activité
normale avant au moins un point est
alors on espère évidemment le vaccin et
mais qui va changer les choses
nicolas je reviens ce que disait jean
noël barrot qui disait que beaucoup
d'entreprises vont être finalement
contrainte à la mutation est ce que vous
qui connaissez très bien le monde de
l'entreprise ce qui ad d action et d ils
sont en cours pour aider justement de
sur le territoire à ces mutations
bien évidemment alors 50 et en yvelines
effectivement l'intercommunalité qui a
la compétence du développement
économique et donc développe à ce titre
là un certain nombre d'actions
on a vous savez l'ouverture du ski
cubain qui est nôtre notre guichet
unique et les entrepreneurs qui est la
maison de l'entreprise et qui
aujourd'hui à une cellule de veille pour
être à l'écouté des entreprises et
surtout relayer toutes les actions
qu'ils existent et les dispositifs qui
ont été mis en place notamment pour
favoriser l'apprentissage et
l'alternance
les stages voilà le gouvernement a mis
en place un certain nombre de choses
beaucoup d'entreprises sont pas encore
pleinement au courant et c'est bien
normal puisque tu vois là il ya beaucoup
de dispositifs qui sont mis en place
donc voilà 50 ans divine essaye de les
relayer autant que faire se peut saint
quentin en yvelines a aussi créé des
écoles du numérique avec cette école qui
ont été labellisés pour accompagner
former nos jeunes ou des personnes en
reconversion sur ces métiers du
numérique qui sont en tension qui sont
fortement demandés par deux entreprises
que ce soit sur la question des données
de la cybersécurité du community
management
tout tout tout ces sujets du numérique
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mise
puissamment dessus pour former nos
jeunes et nos moins jeunes pour répondre
à la forte demande des entreprises du
secteur qui sont basés sur notre
territoire
donc c'est voilà quelques quelques
soucis qui permet d'accompagner le tissu
économique sur ces thématiques qui sont
en tension et qui sont effectivement
plein d'avenir pour pour pour la suite
alors une famille gourdin abordé tout à
l'heure la question des prêts garantis
par l'état les les fameux paix je sais
là c'est la question qu'on va se
soulever
actuellement les pge donc
[Musique]
alors nicolas landry on va puisque on en
est encore à dresser un tableau de la
situation
ses intérêts c'est donc à ces aides
comment ça se passe notamment dans le
territoire des yvelines lens l'epg une
enveloppe de 300 milliards cc conséquent
et historique les entreprises peuvent
obtenir un crédit et ce crédit et
garantie par l'état est bien dans le
département des yvelines selon les
chiffres du 20 novembre communiqués par
le ministère de l'économie et des
finances mais il ya dix mille six cent
cinquante sept entreprises qui ont
bénéficié du pge dans les yvelines
depuis le mois de mars 95 % sont des tpe
pme et ça représente une enveloppe de 2
milliards 155 millions d'euros
plusieurs secteurs sont concernés 20%
c'est dans le secteur de la réparation
d'automobiles et motocycles 14% ses
activités spécialisées scientifiques et
techniques la recherche et développement
sûrement ce doit être des entreprises de
l'aéronautique et de l'automobile
présente un département 13 % c'est la
construction et 10,5 pour cent mais ça
concerne l'hébergement et la
restauration dans le département des
yvelines l'eure et briques de la
boissière évidemment les pg e passe pas
par les banques
techniquement ça marche comme on a on a
un prêt et un remboursement dans les
coins cinquante six ans ça dépend des
dca alors en fait d'abord les chiffres
de nicolas sont exactes j'ai les mêmes
germes a les mêmes sources
alors les pge ils restent sur six ans
que l'égal des petites évolutions qui
ont été annoncées par le ministre à
l'économie notamment la principale est
de dire on pourrait souscrire jusqu'au
30 juin 2021
ensuite que la durée de six ans resté la
durée de normes qui avait pas de souci
mais qu'en revanche on pouvait octroyer
une année différé ce qui veut dire que
je je souscris 1 pg e
la première année l'année dans laquelle
on est qui va aller jusqu'au mois de
mars pour ceux qui avaient souscrit
c'était une année de franchises et les
établissements sont en train de
contacter en ce moment lors les clients
qui avaient souscrit en leur proposant
deux options
enfin trois options soit je rembourse
je n'ai pas besoin de cet argent je ne
veux pas hypothéquer ma capacité
d'endettement
donc je rembourse la somme que j'avais
emprunté soit je suis en mesure de dire
que mon enveloppe me convient ou que je
j'avais emprunté 10 mille je remboursé
les 10000 où j'ai obtenu que je veux
c'est que 5000 mais je commence mon
remboursement et là j'ai choisi les
durées de remboursement deux trois
quatre cinq ans soit jeudi
je ne suis pas serein sur l'avenir et je
veux des cas les remboursements du nat
et et à ce moment là j'ai une année de
franchise en plus mais je ne
remporterais vous crédite toujours sur
une durée maximum de six ans que je la
rembourse serait en quatre ans cette
sorte de sas et la façon dont on n'a pas
aujourd'hui et nient place de systèmes
donc ça a été mis en place en plus les
établissements s'est ouvert et voilà je
vous disais on a des premiers contacts
en revanche on voit aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a une très forte recrudescence de
souscripteurs de nouveau et j'ai eu deux
accidents qu'ils souhaitent des pg e
puisque j'ai des chiffres pour la
semaine dernière
il ya quinze jours on avait eu 3900
demande la semaine dernière les 4900
demanderez pour 500 millions et 16 et
cette semaine pour 877 millions annoncé
l'accélération des normes voilà ça
redonne alors ça c'est pour la région
c'est pour la région sans la région
d'île de france
ouvrons quoique la tendance est quand
même
et quand même là depuis quinze jours
trois semaines depuis qu'on a rogné
depuis qu'on reparle du pge et de
comprendre en phase d'amortissement ou
les gens commencent à réfléchir à peu
sur les bases sur lesquelles ils vont
payer pour les remboursements sur les
quarts en vous avez recours au pge
oui alors est ce que ça fonctionne bien
selon vous est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
des améliorations
alors côté des ad sécurité incendie oui
ça a fonctionné
ç'a bien fonctionné on l'a vu on me l'a
proposé que je l'accepté parce que j'ai
préféré voir un peu
si au niveau de l'avenir côté à pas de
loup evreux le magasin lui par contre
c'est là que je mets un bémol puisque
malgré des bilans l équilibre on a quand
même subi les comment le lait gilet
jaune on a subi les les retraites le
confinement
même s'il est très compliqué pour les
commerçants c'est ça même avec un bilan
favorable les banques qu'on était un peu
moins convaincu pour nous donner le pg
vous avez obtenu quand même ou non pas
du tout non pas du tout un peu frileux
bon c'est pas grave dans le sens où j'ai
enfin c'est pas grave j'ai j'avais un
peu de un peu de cash flow donc du coup
je pioche un peu sur le sur les cachots
monsieur je sais de la voici comment ça
se passe alors là les banques examinées
situation comme andreu le pge a été
étudié en trois 3 niveaux de décision
première décision locale que votre
chargé de clientèle fait son analyse 20%
du chiffre d'affaires ou enfin l'afrique
prend ses ratios il regarde il peut
accorder à hauteur de sa quote part de
mouvements si vous n'avez qu'une banque
c'est que d'un seul qui si le mouvement
est partagé entre deux établissements
chacun fait 50%
si la personne en local refuse le
dossier et qui dit man à la banque
populaire suis présent on n'avait pas le
droit de refuser un dossier l'app ce
dossier est ensuite envoyé au service
crédit
qu'est-ce qui le service crédit estimé
que vraiment il y avait du risque ont
conseillé à notre client d'aller à la
banque de france directement à la
médiation et la banque de france
analyser leur le taux de refus
au niveau national il est de 0 7%
c'est très peu il y en a mais c'est très
très peu
on a même accordé des dossiers à des
gens qui était en procédure de
redressement
voilà donc donc si je peux que vous
encourager à russell cité
l'établissement ce que normalement il
n'y a pas de raison de refuser les
carottes vous cette procédure s'est mise
en place afin votre banquier vous a dit
vais aller voir la banque de france au
tout non mais c'est une très bonne
c'est là pas de réponse est donc je vais
en profiter pour relancer le dossier
commander des établissements très
structuré en fait c'est le pôle le
principe d' escalade qui ne fonctionne
pas agresser un peu ce qu'on a essayé de
mettre avec le medef d'assez pme c'est à
dire voir la cci et la chambre de
métiers sert d'être un peu tiers de
confiance c'est à dire que l'on m'avait
demandé au président de ces entités de
ne pas hésiter à nous contacter en
disant vas monde sans qu'on puisse
escalader parce que vraiment faim moi
j'en ai vu des dossiers refusés
on était d'accord avec la banque de
france il y avait vraiment rien en paix
voilà
magasins qui fonctionnent très bien
enfin voilà libres et pas présent
excréments décollage vous aviez xavier
gourmand vous avez eu recours vaut s'y
opposer vous le disiez vous avez tout à
fait on a activé une première enveloppe
de paix jeu alors papa la totalité il
est plus fort probable serait qu'une
soyons amenés en réclame une deuxième
enveloppe début d'année selon ce qu'on
va pouvoir se dessiner en tout cas sur
l'exercice 2010 t1
là on est fait tout s'est plutôt bien
passé je dirais en tout cas il n'y a pas
eu de difficultés particulières à
obtenir c'est évidemment que la
situation même de l'entreprise au sens
je dirais de son secteur d'activité
aussi fortement contribuer à la prise en
compte au delà même des mandats l'aspect
très sain ce qu est l aspect financier
de l'entreprise
et vous ça s'est passé sans aucun
problème juste dans le calcul des chefs
d'entreprise quand on demande un prêt
c'est quand même qu'on a une sorte de
confiance dans dans ce qui va se passer
dans l'est dans les mois ou dans les
années qui viennent
il faut garder le conte la confiance est
un chef d'entreprise c'est dire que par
la confiance le bateau tangue un peu
même beaucoup et donc du coup c'est un
peu ce que je disais au tout début c'est
de garder cette confiance ne pas faire
voir que l'avenir n'est peut-être pas si
6 éclairé que ça mais en tout cas il
faut garder cette dynamique de façon à
ce que
l'ensemble des collaborateurs rentrer
dans le dans ce dynamisme et permettre
de pouvoir continuer de d'affronter un
peu l'avenir si aujourd'hui on sait pas
trop comment ça se passait dit que la
wii une infortune demande d'information
pour il m'arrive de la boissière
peut-être qu'il va me le confirmer cette
information
il me semble que l'état propose des
prêts participatifs c'était c'est à dire
que l'état prête directement aux
entreprises pour les entreprises qui ont
reçu un refus de pge c'est bien ça non
non alors c'est parce que j'avais comme
information il y avait un débat qui a
été lancée pour savoir si on pouvait on
s'appelle mettre en place
enfin effet demandé que l'option de
transformer le pge toyer en prison en
transformation en capital de
l'entreprise
c'est très compliqué pour nous parce
qu'on n'a pas vocation à monter au
capital des entreprises
c'est compliqué pour l'état même s'il va
le faire pour air france et il va
doubler sa participation mais c'est
aujourd'hui c'est pas faisable
en revanche il y a et où l'avait les
prêts rebond qui sont montés par la
région et parole des pays qui sont une
autre opportunité de capter un peu de
fond mais nous on n'a pas vocation à
monter au capital à nyon prêtent de
l'argent on se fait rembourser mais non
pas au capital et 7 cette option
elle n'a pas les faveurs de la lb et
l'autre interrogation que j'avais si on
le voit avec eux monsieur avant
finalement c'est il a anticipé l'avenir
on retrouve beaucoup de si et si cette
situation finalement dans la presse
économique on lit beaucoup que certains
chefs d'entreprise ont pris un psg où il
en avait pas forcément besoin mais ils
l'ont pris au cas où pour anticiper
l'avenir
alors c'est vrai que nous on a très très
bien à lui dans nos bilans des banques
on a lu la courbe des crédits qui est
monté et avec un écart derrière on a vu
la courbe des placements qui est monté
aussi c'est beaucoup ont placé la
trésorerie c'est pour ça que je disais
que là les questions qui arrive
aujourd'hui c'est de dire qu'on filme
rapidement ça va continuer deuxième cris
de troisième vague opportunité je sais
pas les les taux de remboursement des
crédits seront je m'engage pas pour les
établissements on est en gros on estime
que ce qu'ils rembourseront sur la durée
la plus longue à 5 ans ça ne dépassera
et 2%
voilà donc cesser des taux qui sont en
termes de trésorerie très acceptable si
vous empruntez aujourd'hui sur des
trésoreries des caisses à la 3e rue bord
plus de vous avez dû 3% vous avez dû 3/2
enfin voilà ça va être quelque chose de
très raisonnable les établissements
s'étaient engagés sous amical conseils
du ministère de l'économie à limiter les
frais c'est à dire qu'on a analysé un
peu le risque et on a le coût de
fonctionnement pas de marge
et voilà ça a été très raisonnable
nicolas david la trésorerie il ya de la
trésorerie est ce que vous disiez est
très vrai monsieur bourdin
c'est maintenant que se décide est-ce
que j'en reprends une taupe est est-ce
que je tape dedans est ce que je
rembourse
est ce que est ce que je garde de la
trésorerie à 2%
ce sont les arbitres nicolas david sur
le territoire vous avez des retours des
chefs d'entreprise ça se passe plutôt
bien
le système des pg e justement écouter ou
là on a effectivement quelques quelques
retours donc le pge est analysée comme
une bouée de sauvetage pour les
entreprises qui ont eu la chance de
l'avoir
mais mais mais il ya quand même une
forte inquiétude qui persistent
notamment dans les secteurs qu'on a
évoqué celui de la restauration de
l'événementiel du tourisme donc voilà je
dirais s'il bouée de sauvetage qui leur
a permis de maintenir la tête hors de
l'eau mais il faudra à mon avis encore
les souvenirs
si on veut qu'ils résistent qui
résistent à cette deuxième vague alors
on va on va aborder la question des
perspectives évidemment avec notamment
le plan de relance mais on va commencer
par un sujet que vous avez réalisé sur
deux entreprises qui ont obtenu des
aides de la région ile de france
justement et qui sont en pleine mutation
c'est exactement ça la région ile de
france a lancé le programme relance
l'industrie
l'objectif c'est de financer des projets
proposés par des pme tpe dans
l'industrie francilienne 75 projets ont
été sélectionnés pour une enveloppe de
42 5 millions d'euros deux entreprises
situées sur le territoire en ont
bénéficié du territoire de saint quentin
en yvelines gamme et cas à guyancourt et
mécanique ateliers de coignières
regarder elle est spécialisée dans
l'industrie de précision l'entreprise
mécanique ateliers de coignières
fabrique des pièces à partir de machines
à commande numérique
elle réalise plus de 80% de son activité
dans l'aéronautique impacté par la crise
sanitaire cette pme de 26 salariés à
décrocher une aide de la région
ile-de-france 450000 euros pour son
projet d'investissement
cette aide va nous permettre de
de continuer à moderniser notre outil de
production à robotiser robotisée et
digitalisées numériser toutes les
informations qu'on peut avoir
aujourd'hui et en suivi de production
le but est de continuer à
diversification sur la partie clientèle
qu'on avait où on a une clientèle qui
était très érotique et qui
malheureusement a été fortement impacté
avec la baisse du trafic aérien
et aujourd'hui on va essayer de se
reconvertir sur le secteur ferroviaire
ou aux militaires ou peut-être
automobile
du côté de guyancourt la société gas
mika fabrique des pièces pour des
prototypes de l'industrie automobile et
pétrolières face à la crise et une
baisse d'activité entre 20 et 30%
cette entreprise a mis en place un prêt
garanti par l'état et reporter les
charges sociales et fiscales pour se
relancer elle souhaite investir 800
mille euros sur trois ans dont 350 mille
euros de subventions obtenues auprès du
conseil régional
alors notre axe c'est surtout de
développer tout ce qui est digital
puisqu'aujourd'hui on reçoit des plans
en 3d numérisés on les envoie sur nos
machines
donc on a encore des machines numériques
à acquérir on va essayer d'aller
chercher des marchés surtout ce que
l'hydrogène par rapport à tout ce qui
est moteur électrique également ici se
redéployer sur tout ce qui est médicale
spatiale est également tous cas défense
au total dans le département des
yvelines 16 entreprises ont été
sélectionnées pour obtenir une
subvention de la région des projets
allant de la relocalisation d'activités
à la modernisation d'outils de
production une enveloppe globale de 10
millions 250 mille euros on va donc
passer aux perspectives des plans de
relance mais auparavant jean becker dont
vous aviez une précision encore demandé
sur les prés de la boissière tout à fait
donc du coup voilà aujourd'hui toute
entreprise à des prêts en cours
on a eu au premier confinement on a eu
la possibilité sur sur demande auprès
nos banquiers de le décaler de six mois
et on s'est aperçu enfin moi je me suis
aperçu de mon côté concernant les deux
sociétés comptent continuer à payer les
intérêts pas le capital mais les
intérêts sur la base de six mois est au
bout des six mois on avait un appel de
notre notre conseiller pour savoir si on
voulait rembourser les 6 mois qui
étaient décalés ou alors de décaler dans
le temps le plan de financement
donc moi je suis partie sur sur un sur
une société où j'ai payé directement les
six mois qui était décalée c'est aider à
d par contre pour à pas de loup g2 j'ai
demandé à ce qu'on le doit un plan de
financement on me le on me le prolonge
de sites de de six mois ce qui a été
fait mais je me suis retrouvé pu avec
six mois mais avec sept mois un mois
supplémentaire qui aujourd'hui je
demande mais j'arrive pas à voir cette
réponse savoir si c'est pas un mois
d'intérêts sur les pénalités de décalage
de six mois ou ou une forme de calcul du
plan de financement
vous pouvez juste l'échéance n'a pas
bougé la satire échéance est la même non
la 7e échéance par exemple pour mon
magasin gt gt jusqu'à fin novembre
donc cette année pour évidemment mon
commandement
mon prêt mais il a été décalé de six
mois sur l'année de 2021 et des six mois
je me suis retrouvé qu'un mois
supplémentaires oui mais ils paient
toujours mille euros par mois oui ça
mais en fait ce qu'ils aient ce qui
s'est passé c'est que aux conserveries
même échéance de 1000 euros par mois ils
ont refait un calcul en réintégrant une
partie de capita une partie d'intérêt de
manière à ce que tout soit payée sur la
même base de 1000 euros d'où ce septième
mois supplémentaires dans l'idée parce
que sinon on aurait pu vous faire une
échéance la dernière de l'orge et il
faudra le contrat mais une dernière
échéance de 600 euros ou de 1300 euros
s'il avait gardé que sur six mois que si
sûr si déchéance politique je veux dire
on a payé pendant six mois des intérêts
qui était sur le plan de financement
initial qui n'avait pas été remboursés
ou faire une échéance global plus
importante d'un seul coup ils ont dit on
va en faire une septième qui permet de
maintenir la mensualité et de tout
intégrer le dos merci pour ce que tu es
mandat fort bien fait de venir ça fait
dans la journée
alors va pas c'est justement maintenant
aux perspectives qu'est ce qui va se
passer en 2021
[Musique]
d'abord posé de questions un peu général
qui nous éloignent peut-être du
territoire ils sont importantes on
constate qu'il ya très peu d'inflation
en france comment elle explique ça je
suis pas un grand économiste mais on
sait que l'inflation elle dépend de
trois quatre critères primordiaux
le premier c'est l'aele plus important
notamment pour les chefs d'entreprise
c'est la faiblesse des coûts salariaux
la maîtrise des salaires la dette pose
celle
ça c est ça c'est induit par voit le
chômage
il ya un rapport de force qui se crée
entre les offres d'emploi et les
demandeurs et aujourd'hui le moment bien
on est des autres qu'ils soient pas
pourvues en appareils plus de demandeurs
ça ça maintient que ça a l'air assez bas
il ya une une une l'ouverture d'une
moindre rigidités sur la faction de
fixer les prix aujourd'hui la
concurrence fait que les prix bas sont
en dur ouais on a eu le débat avec les
commerçants et le black friday et les
géants de l'internet
ça maintient les prix assez bas ensuite
il ya un pool eurent un peu plus macro
qui est la politique monétaire qui
émanait d'une façon globale au niveau de
l'europe des taux bas de la liquidité
il ya plus de dévaluation enfin il ya
plus de balkanisation des économies
européennes donc c'est sur la même base
avec de l'euro où ce sont des troupes de
ce pays qui ne sont pas encore dans
l'euro donc ça ça stabilise 7,7 cette
masse monétaire
et puis et puis il ya un peu de crise et
qui dit qu ils moins de débouchés moins
de ventes moins de vent ça impacte sur
les négativement sur des prises ces
quatre secteurs qui font bouger de sang
est alors question qui constate plus les
banques elle est ce qu on peut tabler
sur une stabilité des taux d'intérêt
alors aujourd'hui clairement
dès que des indicateurs qui nous disent
que les taux ne bouge pas quand on
regarde les prêts on apporte quoi mais
n'importe quoi d'ailleurs
en août on était 1,31 en septembre on
est 1 30 en moyenne sur les prêts
immobiliers pour les entreprises
on est à 74 3 en moyenne sur les prêts
aux entreprises
donc on n'a vraiment pas tendance à la
hausse des taux alors malheureusement
pour nous un sûr mais on reste très très
stable et puis on a des contraintes
réglementaires sur la partie immobilière
particulier ça on en avait déjà parlé
avec le nicolas sur les tendances du hcf
l'auto me conseille la sécurité
financière qui nous a demandé de
restreindre un peu les critères d'octroi
des crédits un puce d'apport des durées
limitées dans le temps pas plus de 25
ans le taux d'endettement qui est revenu
à 33%
voilà ça à ça ça ne concourent pas à
voir une hausse des taux nicolas david o
disiez tout à l'heure qu'il ya un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes dans
certains secteurs l'aéronautique
l'automobile la restauration le tourisme
est en même temps est ce que il ya des
perspectives peut-être l'arrivée du
vaccin
peut-être
la victoire contre le virus qui pourrait
quand même nous nous ouvrir des
perspectives plus réjouissantes plus
optimistes en tout cas bien évidemment
je sais que le mot crise en chinois
c'est à la fois le chaos et c'est
l'opportunité et il faut effectivement
qu'on s'inscrivent aussi dans les
nouvelles opportunités à saisir
on a effectivement des red et des
événements qui vont je pense être très
positive en tout cas sur notre
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
je pense aux jo au jo de 2024 avec les
épreuves qui vont avoir lieu sur le
territoire dans notre vélodrome dans
l'est de loisirs sur la colline
d'elancourt à versailles
à quelques kilomètres de chez nous donc
il ya effectivement des événements qui
vont être très importants pour le
territoire en terme d'accueil des
athlètes de tourisme et qui vont je
pense contribué en tout cas mettre une
petite habite dans notre territoire
on a tout cette transition numérique on
en a parlé avec eux dans dés à présent
une formation qui est intensifiée dans
ces secteurs on à paris saclay qui
également se renforce de jour en jour et
il s'impose comme le premier
l'un des premiers pôles universitaires
mondiaux avec d'excellents résultats
donc on a effectivement beaucoup de je
dirais de tendance d'événements qui sont
plutôt positives pour notre territoire
et il faut essayer de miser sur ce qui
marche et clairement que ce soit sur le
sport que ce soit sur l'université que
ce soit sur le numérique notre
territoire est très bien positionné
alors on va avoir trouvé de jean-noël
barrot député de la 2e circonscription
des yvelines justement les perspectives
de croissance de 2021 sur deux de plus
de 6% en france qui est pratiquement
quatre points de plus que l'allemagne
qui est quand même pas mal et autres jus
demandé si on pouvait justement croire à
cette bonne bonnes prévisions
je crois qu'on peut y croire pour pour
deux raisons ce qu'il explique en partie
ses perspectives c'est que
la chute est tellement importante en
2020 concots qu'il ya un phénomène
presque mathématique de rebond c'est à
dire que à mesure que l'économie va
retrouver son régime de croisière
on voit par rapport au creux de 2020
observé des taux de croissance
importants
mais au-delà de ça je crois que et sans
méconnaître un délai fragilité que j'ai
évoqués en réponse à vos premières
questions
je crois qu'il ya il ya un motif
d'espoir et qui résident dans le jeu
d'hier est là la probabilité croissante
de jour en jour qu'à l'horizon de la fin
de l'année 2000 21 dans les pays de l'
ocde notamment ils puissent on puisse se
disposer de vaccins et des campagnes de
vaccination ait pu avoir lieu alors
parler du plan de relance et il est de
100 milliards dont 40 milliards viennent
devraient venir de l'europe ce décompte
il s'appelle avec avec deux pays
notamment et quel meilleur usage trop
comment faire parce que ce sont pas des
téoz tête mais sont des dépenses
d'investissement l'a donc quels domaines
faut-il investir notamment dans ce temps
dans les yvelines
l'écouté il ya un axe qui est évidemment
prioritaire c'est celui de la transition
écologique qui va faire l'objet de
plusieurs dispositifs ceux qui sont déjà
mises en oeuvre c'est ou en tout cas
pour lesquels les appels à projets ont
d'ores et déjà été lancée c'est la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics les collectivités vont pouvoir
elles aussi bénéficier de soutien très
important pour la rénovation de leurs
bâtiments et l'industrie c'est à dire
les entreprises pourront elles aussi
émarger sur des dispositifs de
subvention à la décarbonation donc ça
c'est évidemment la kz prioritaire mais
il ya aussi d'autres
d'autres axes qui sont visés par ce plan
de relance qui comme vous le rappelez il
ya la compétitivité
exactement exactement il ya aussi la la
la numérisation et la
réindustrialisation ou la relocalisation
d'un certain nombre d'activités
c'est donc là il ya certain nombre de
deux dispositifs qui sont accessibles
aux entreprises et d'ailleurs où loge en
josas
une entreprise a été lauréate de l'un de
ses premiers appels à projets et cela a
été annoncé la semaine dernière et et
ses dispositifs vont permettre de
renforcer notre tissu industriel qui
s'était très largement dégradée même si
depuis quelques années la chute qui
semblait irrémédiable de l'emploi
industriel s'était ralentie donc voilà
la transition écologique
la relocalisation et puis la
digitalisation et ça ça concerne
évidemment tout le spectre de la grande
entreprise industrielle jusqu aux
commerçants puisque vous savez qu'on a
mis en place un certain nombre d' aide
des aides de l'état mais aussi les
collectivités de la région ile de france
pour accompagner les commerçants dans
leur digitalisation ajustements
accompagner les commerçants dans leur
dise utilisation j'en ai 40 vous avez
été vous accompagne en vous a aidé on
vous a donné conseillé entre les deux
confinement j'ai essayé de le relancer
afin de me lancer dans la numérisation
surtout faire d un e-commerce et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que entre les
aides ne seront pas non plus dire qu'il
n'ya pas dead
il ya des aides elles sont bien mais par
contre elle sont pas en adéquation avec
les tarifs les vrais tarif de
création de site e commerce donc ça nous
fait un écart après il faut aussi
rentrer dans dynamisme et dire on
s'investit on prend le risque de
réinvestir pour avoir un e-commerce pour
ne pas subir ce qu'on a subi là entre
les deux confinement et se retrouver un
peu sans minima donc en faisant des dt
commander des collectes ou des drive
pour essayer de minimiser un peu le lait
pertinents nicolas termine justement sur
les trois points soulevés
jean-noël barrot c'est à dire la
transition écologique avec la rénovation
et la construction de bâtiments la
réindustrialisation la numérisation est
ce qu'il ya des chantiers dans ces
domaines sur le territoire vous êtes
responsable bien évidemment sur eux tout
ce qui concerne la formation dans à
parler à la fois sur le numérique avec
nos écoles du numérique que l'on a
considérablement renforcé à la fois même
des nos écoles primaires où il ya eu un
accent particulier mis sur l'initiation
à la programmation informatique avec
l'arrivée d'outils pédagogiques les plus
innovants dans toutes nos écoles de
saint quentin
que ce soit des petits robots pour nos
enfants l'été a ni les tableaux
numériques interactifs
les cours d'anglais par visioconférence
bref tout un ensemble d'outils pour
initier dès le plus jeune âge nos jeunes
à cette culture numérique qui sera
d'autant plus importante demain avec
paris saclay on en a parlé
et puis surtout l'accompagnement des
entreprises
saint quentin en yvelines a aussi mis en
place un certain nombre d'outils
notamment liés aux prêts avec
l'initiative 50 ans qui est vous savez
la plateforme qui est destiné à faire
des prêts à taux zéro adossés à des
prêts bancaires pour soutenir autant que
faire se peut tous ces secteurs qui sont
soit en difficulté soit qui ont besoin
d'avoir de la trésorerie pour continuer
d'innover d'embauché donc on a mis en
place des outils jeudi elle est très
très concret à destination de
tous ces secteurs et puis on a mis aussi
en place une plateforme qui s'appelle
ski emploi.fr pour justement renforcée
je dirais la la la rencontre entre
l'offre et la demande d'emploi pour que
les entreprises qui recherchent des
talents puissent avoir accès à toute une
cvthèque dans de talents issus du
territoire
on a également mis en place des
événements à la fois en lire les
webinaires pour permettre malgré le
confinement de de permettre cette
rencontre entre l'offre et la demande
et puis des événements qui vont être
maintenues avec en piste pour l'emploi
qui est d'autres grands événements
emploi pour permettre à ces secteurs qui
recrutent de trouver leur talent et ça
sera au vélodrome nationale dans
quelques mois dès que la situation
sanitaire le permettra vous venez ici
car en double des manades gire
photo mm avec de la boissière en un mot
les grandes demandes des entreprises
c'est plutôt de l'aide immédiate ou
c'est de l'aide pour justement la
mutation de ces entreprises on parlait
de la digitalisation notamment et
devoirs des mutations en fonction de
d'une perte des perspectives d'avenir
alors quand ça vient des entreprises du
classique 1 c'est celle pour l'activité
classique crédits placements
accompagnement de deux projets en
revanche viennent des établissements
bancaires des offres de services
notamment ce qu'on utilisait dans le
tout des établissements ont des
partenariats avec les structures pour
mettre en place delà des sites internet
je sais que nous on a montré une grosse
opération sur saint germain avec l'union
des commerçants avec des plugins leur
amiante
on a créé la marketplace de saint
germain et on va le développer dans
d'autres villes des yvelines faire que
tous les commerçants se regroupent et
nous
on importe notre solution informatique
notre solution paiement de manière à ce
qu'il puisse mettre en place ce site
internet local pour que chacun puisse
vendre fait chacun propose ses produits
le craignant pas cliquer dans chacune
des boutiques et ne fait qu un seul
paiement et nous on se charge de re
dispatcher d'argent à chacune des
boutiques ça c'est typiquement le
solution que tous les établissements
aujourd'hui propose où ils cei de
proposer
on a des solutions paiement informatique
voilà on accompagne on propose des
solutions pardon puisque vous êtes dans
un secteur qui est évidemment
particulièrement touché par la crise et
quelles sont vos perspectives pour
l'année prochaine vous êtes vous êtes
quand même optimiste vous pensez sans
jeu aussi dans la façon de gérer votre
activité
alors optimiste comment elle s'était
tout à l'heure où il le faut bien
évidemment sinon je pense qu'on fonde en
ré quelques soucis pour entrer en
entraîner la société dans que oui on est
on est optimiste même si la difficulté
est vraiment la visibilité qu'on a sur
cette situation de crise en tout cas sur
la fin la fin de cette crise
c'est en effet aussi une façon de se
transformer pour de marc puisque
nécessairement des choses vont rester
près de nantes dans le comportement du
quotidien donc on a pu induire avec
cette crise je pense notamment pour ce
qui concerne l'activité par rapport aux
entreprises il ya une prestation de type
plateaux-repas évidemment quand les
collaborateurs seront de plus en plus en
télétravail ce qui sera le cas y compris
demain il faut qu'on réfléchisse à une
autre forme je dirais de distribuer des
services et peut-être plutôt que de
distribuer les plateaux indirectement un
livre dans l'entreprise il faudra on
s'organise en tout cas pour les livrer
directement domicile des salariés
lorsque ceux ci seront intégrés y voilà
ça fait partie de ces quelques éléments
de transformation il ya nécessairement
plein d'autres points qui qui qui
amélioreront aussi à la façon dont les
gens consomment 1 et donc il faudra
gérer concia donc on est optimiste on a
en effet cette phase de transformation
qui nous amène aussi à changer un peu
les postures et la stratégie qu'on avait
pu inscrire les années passées dans
notre dans l'autre
je dirais un chemin pour pouvoir en
effet faire face à sète
ce rebond l'espère post crise mais je
vous dis la vraie difficulté aujourd'hui
est plutôt la visibilité qu'on a sur à
quel moment cette crise le finir par
être derrière nous oui c'est ça c'est
vraiment le fait de ne pas savoir d'être
dans la certitude qu'ils posent pour
loeb c est exactement votre problème
aussi mais vous êtes aussi optimiste il
faut la sortie de jean des cars ans il
le faut merci infiniment merci jean
lucas rang merci xavier gourna m'inscris
aymeric de la boissière merci nicolas
david et mercy de collaborer et à très
vite pour un nouveau numéro de popov
[Musique]